- [Instructor] Earlier in
our mathematical adventures,
we had expanded things like x plus y
times x minus y.
Just as a but of review,
this is going to be equal to
x times x, which is x squared;
plus x times negative
y, which is negative xy;
plus y times x, which is plus xy;
and then minus y times y.
Or you could say y times a negative y,
so it's going to be minus y squared.
Negative xy, positive xy, so
this is just going to simplify
to x squared minus y squared.
And this is all review.
We covered it, and when we
thought about factoring things
that are differences of squares,
we thought about this when we were
first learning to multiply binomials.
And what we're going to do now is
essentially just do the same thing,
but do it with slightly more
complicated expressions.
And so, another way of
expressing what we just did
is we could also write something like
a plus b times a minus b is
going to be equal to what?
Well, it's going to be equal
to a squared minus b squared.
The only difference between what I did
up here and what I did over here
is instead of an x, I wrote an a;
and instead of a y, I wrote a b.
So, given that, let's see if we can expand
and then combine like terms for,
if I'm multiplying these two expressions.
Say I'm multiplying three
plus 5x to the fourth
times three minus 5x to the fourth.
Pause this video, and see
if you can work this out.
Alright, well, there's
two ways to approach it.
You could just approach it exactly the way
that I approached it up here,
but we already know that
when we have this pattern
where we have something plus something
times that same original something
minus the other something,
well that's going to be of the form
of this thing squared
minus this thing squared.
And remember, the only
reason why I'm applying that
is I have a three right
over here and here,
so the three is playing the role of the a.
So, let me write that down, that is our a.
And then the role of the b
is being played by 5x to the fourth.
So, that is our b right over there.
So, this is going to be equal
to a squared minus b squared.
But our a is three,
so it's going to be
equal to three squared,
minus, and then our b is 5x to the fourth,
minus 5x to the fourth squared.
Now, what does all of this simplify to?
Well, this is going to be equal to,
three squared is nine, and then minus
5x to the fourth squared.
Let's see, 5 squared is 25.
And then x to the fourth squared,
well, that is just going
to be x to the fourth
times x to the fourth, which
is just x to the eighth.
Another way to think about
it are exponent properties.
This is the same thing as 5 squared
times x to the fourth squared.
If I raise something to an exponent
and then raise that to another exponent,
I multiply the exponents.
And there you have it.
Let's do another example.
Let's say that I were to ask you,
what is 3y squared
plus 2y to the fifth
times 3y squared
minus 2y to the fifth?
Pause this video, and see
if you can work that out.
Well, we're going to do it the same way.
You could, of course, always
just try to expand it out
the way we did originally.
But we could recognize here that, hey,
I have an a plus a b
times the a minus a b.
So, that's going to be
equal to our a squared.
So, what's 3y squared?
Well, that's going to be 9y to the fourth
minus our b squared.
Well, what's 2y to the fifth squared?
Well, 2 squared is four,
and y to the fifth squared
is y to the five times
two, y to the 10th power.
And there's no further
simplification that I could do here.
I can't combine any like terms.
And so, we are done here as well.